how's it going guys my name is matt and
today i'm going to give you a quick run
through
of how to get nvidia physics set up with
your c
plus plus a little disclaimer here
windows
visual studio you're using a different
platform that's fine
it should be about the same your setup
and linking the library and getting the
sdk
might be a little bit different but
that's okay because we got this thing
called google
and if you just search for physics we'll
find some stuff about it
now if we look at a brief overview of
physics we can get a pretty good idea of
what's going on here it's basically a
world and objects
and you define scenes which encompass
all of a set of actors actors in
different scenes do not interact so you
can
set up multiple scenes and they have
characters and vehicles and complex
specialized objects made from actors
actors have physical state position
orientation velocity momentum energy
actor
physical state may evolve over time to
light forces pretty standard
physics stuff i'm going to walk you
through all of my steps
that i take to get this running and a
piece of software of my own like say
a game engine or something but it could
be for whatever emulation you want to do
for science and
stuff too so you would naturally think
that you go get this sdk
this is actually a great idea but we
actually don't need it for the way we're
going to do it because
we're going to be using a packet manager
called vc
ekg this is just going to allow us to
install in video physics and have it
ready for
our default visual studio environment
it's very handy because it's
very straightforward we literally just
type in install
physics of course you'd want to do
search first and there it is it says it
finds it
version 4.2 so all you would have to do
is just install it and do the integrate
install and all that stuff i have a
video on this
if you'd like to see it and also there's
documentation on vcpkg if you totally
lost this step but this should be
the easy part because it's it's your
library manager however you do it for
your system normally it's going to be
the same basically
so if you're using conan or whatever
it's it's fine so yeah all you would do
is install
physics already installed so now
i will say the good thing about this sdk
there's a lot of examples and stuff
within it
so if you want to play around with some
of the pre-built examples i believe
they're in this sdk
we've got the library installed that's
good enough to start coding with it now
let's open visual
studio and we're just going to do a new
project you can do this with cmake
we should get some instructions uh yeah
we'll basically have to include with cma
instructions don't show here but i think
when you first install it they should
basically you'll just have find package
stuff we're just going to use an empty
project
called this physics setup and there we
go so we're just going to right away
just right click on our top level
project
go to add and new item and let's just
make a main if it's super clean you
should be able to just do it all in a
main
search physics docs here they are 4.1 is
the version we have
and in all of this you will find a lot
of basic examples this is where you go
next if you're stuck
i would say for now we're just going to
pull in a bunch of code
this basically all comes from one of the
snippets and we're just going to put it
in a mate so we can handle everything in
the main course need to include
physics oh it's not showing up because
we're in x86
we want to be sure to change this to x64
or whatever
library you downloaded you may have
noticed earlier that this was a 64-bit
version now we should see it
it's just called physics bx physics
there it is i think we just need this
base one that gets us most of it about
the api
the api gets us the rest okay now we're
just going to walk through and
initialize all these so what are
all these you might ask i will probably
mess up the explanation
so you're welcome to go look them up but
i'll give you
my best rundown of what i understand to
be i just want to come with the
disclaimer that i could be wrong so
basically we need to initialize the
world
a lot of this is actually debugger stuff
pvd is physics visual debug or something
you can grab from their website
under downloads so you run this when
you're running your program so that's
what this pvd is so you can have more
than one scene materials we're going to
kind of see too it's what you apply to
different objects
physics is kind of the core
substantiation here
the foundation believe it's all your
settings for how
it initializes and stuff tolerance scale
has to do with
how it processes uh colliders and stuff
the dispatcher i believe this is going
to be used to dispatch work to different
cpus
multi-threading now this default error
callback and default allocator callback
i'm not sure how to explain them
[Music]
am i so now we've declared all this
stuff we want to create a world
basically or let's go
with the rest of the directions knit
physics then we basically want to create
simulation we'll say and then like run
the simulation so those are the general
steps
we're going to go through here this one
up here i guess i'm sticking with this
theme would be declare variables now
depending on how your software is
this topic i don't really want to dive
off into you could have this in all
sorts of different ways you could set
classes you could have a whole
intricate system that you designed
around the api for your particular thing
but in general you got to have some core
stuff and do
away with a lot of these or shift them
to where they need to be as you'll kind
of start to see later but in general
we're going to be using this stuff for
now all right let's get started shall we
all right we're going to keep this real
simple i'm just going to
just going to bring the code over
it's just how it is for this particular
implementation so let's walk through it
we want to initialize the foundation the
x create foundation ass in the physics
version give it these default allocator
default error callbacks which we're not
actually going to be working with right
now
and immediately we're just going to do a
check and see if it failed to create
so this throw will stop and yell at us
basically which is what we want if it
doesn't work and
next we're going to create our pvd we're
going to use the same foundation this
pvd
is kind of optional it's this visual
debugger so we're creating that
and then we create a transport this
basically is to hook into
a server or something we're just going
to hook into ourselves so
same ip address and these were just
recommended ports and this last one is a
timeout
and then we do a connect using that
transport and we're giving an e-all flag
so i've commented out some stuff from
old versions
uh but you can if you don't want to hold
the tolerance
scale you can just default initialize it
and this create physics
which is what we're doing next but
instead we're holding it and we're
setting some custom values for length
and speed of
objects these were just some recommended
numbers from one of the snippets and
then we of course create the physics
it's going to need a version the
foundation tolerance scale
and the pvd and see what that true thing
was
track outstanding allocations is set to
true
all right and here's another version
that we didn't use and next we set up a
scene so
first we set up a scene description now
this is where we're actually kind of
instantiating world
because at this point the physics is
initialized
and this this is kind of getting into
where we want to set up some sort
we're seeing this case i guess we're
calling so
our scene description we're going to
initialize it with tolerance scale
whatever our physics is
and we're going to set a graph on our
scene descriptions
now this dispatcher we're going to set
it to two that's going to call up to two
threads to handle stuff so
you might want to do this differently
depending on how you're dispatching
there's also gpu dispatching
we're not going to get into that but
maybe for a later video if people are
interested
so we set up the dispatcher on the scene
and then
a filter shader i'm not sure what this
default simulation filter shader does
exactly
set our scene to m physics create scene
with the scene description
so yeah you take your physics so a quick
note on these variable names
yeah they have m on it that's not
necessarily good practice when you're in
a main like this
i just pulled them out of a class one of
my other files so i just kind of left
but uh
just so you're aware name however you
want to name so we're all set up at this
point we have a new scene
so we're going to set our pvd up here a
dvd scene client for this
scene so yeah we just set some uh flags
there constraints contacts
scene queries we want to make a little
simulation so i'll start off here by uh
just making a rigid static because
basically we're going to add
actors rigid bodies any kind of uh
physics body we're going to add as an
actor to the scene
so you basically just do that and
they've got a whole set operating
different planes
they've got convex concave all and
boxes and capsules and whatever you want
you can create it here
ideally you want to get this set up so
they have a colliding system within
whatever you're working with always hear
the term collider boxes that's what
these are these are
glider boxes hope you're uh enjoying the
video all right
so here we have created the material or
set up the material this is the first
time we used it we have it up here as
like a global one because we're just
gonna use it a bunch
but in reality when you're creating
these or if you've set up a system to
create them you might wanna
have different materials all the time so
we gave it some numbers
and the first one static friction sex
dynamic friction the last one
is restitution so we have a ground plane
as a rigid static and we call it great
plane we give it the physics give it
a constructor of a plane so at 99 this
seems to go
down 99 steps we're just gonna put this
at
all right we'll go down one step so it's
a weird constructor
there's other constructors of the plane
i digress
okay so we add the ground plane to a
scene
so to run it basically all you do is
just simulate
you give it a delta time which we're
gonna call one
one of sixty so it's about a sixty frame
per second simulation and then a fetch
results
at the end and this boolean here is a
blocking or setting blocking to true we
should be able to actually run this now
let's give it a go it shouldn't really
do anything
except sit there and these stuff seems
to be stuck in the wild loot stop before
we add a bunch of boxes
let's check the debugger we're gonna
launch this physics and this is what it
looks like i didn't make
any changes to this i literally just
installed it and open and these settings
worked
with the localhost 127.0.0.1 no place
like it okay so we're gonna hit play
and since this is running you see that
it's getting frames same frame count
so it is running the simulation now
we're going to stop here sometimes i
notice that this debugger crashes
your program does weird stuff so your
results may vary might have to close and
reopen it but it does
seem to be picking things up with the
way we have this pvd client set up let's
add in some physics and see what the pvd
does
or not just physics but boxes or
something and once again we are pulling
from snippets that come with the sdk i'm
just going to go over to github
and they have the physics sdk and we'll
go into it again and look at snippets
and we'll see if we can find some basic
code from their hello world
and the reason i'm showing this of
course is to teach you that you can do
the same thing okay let's check these
out you can see
they have some similar stuff but they've
got
so few things set up they have some
stupid comments so you can go look at
those and see what they got going on
i pulled in everything i needed already
so you can see they have a create
dynamic function that returns a rigid
dynamic they have a create stack
function which spawns a whole bunch of
boxes
so we might just spawn a whole bunch of
boxes let's create stack looks like a
good idea
and this other one let's create dynamic
ascend geometries build whatever you
want this one just creates a stack
boxes okay let's create a stack of boxes
obviously my names are different they
have
g physics g material i'm going to change
that all around
to my stuff which is just going to be m
basically on
all of these their half extent is
declared somewhere
and let's just try float and we'll do
these points okay i also need
to put physics in front of this the name
space so of course you could
physics and not type those all the time
in this file totally up to you
i like to know what library's coming
from so i typically don't use this
but this will also explain why all these
underlying squigglies because it doesn't
know
what they are just looking at this
function pass it in they want
you to pass in a transform a size a half
extent decide
equals transform i have it declared like
this
transforms default constructed so fix up
all this code and
it looks pretty good and we got a debug
error looks like this is on the
transform okay no problem looks like it
just needs to be constructed with
something so we're going to pass it a
vec3
that is all zeros and it seems to be
happy with that
so with the size of 50 that's gonna go
through 50
times 50. it's going to be a huge number
we're going to just scale this back to
maybe
30 30 times 30 is not quite as large
because we're getting into exponentials
okay let's go ahead and run this so of
course
when we hit run it's going to go through
this whole thing and get stuck here at
the simulation
there we go and there we go there's our
little simulated stack and it does look
like they fell to the ground
oh can we do anything here hey we can
rotate around that's pretty cool
can try creating bodies in different
positions or however you like and some
interesting things should happen
this will allow you to start playing
around with nvidia physics api
and you're in at this point you're like
able to get this run this is
the meat potatoes do what you want from
here implement it as needed within your
own stuff be sure
to follow whatever their license is the
initialization all right
well hope you enjoyed this video see you
guys in the next one
matt from codetech tutorials over and
out peace guys
[Applause]
[Music]